las mascarillas caseras hechas de tela y
ya no serían una barrera suficiente
contra el coronavirus el ministro de
salud francés origen dijo recomienda a
partir de ahora el uso de máscaras de
grado industrial pues éstas pueden
filtrar el aire al menos en un 90% esto
como medida preventiva ante una nueva
variante del virus que ya preocupa en el
país
para algunos el argumento no convence si
mantenemos el distanciamiento social en
general con otras personas francamente
no creo que las mascarillas quirúrgicas
sean totalmente necesarias pero en los
hospitales la situación se hace cada vez
más crítica una nueva oleada de
contagios obligó al gobierno a endurecer
nuevamente las restricciones pero los
pacientes siguen llegando y los
trabajadores de la salud temen que lo
peor puede estar por venir
pero no juegas tú
estamos un poco ansiosos de que en un
par de semanas tal vez las cifras suban
ya que eso es lo que los institutos de
salud están pronosticando así que
estamos contando mucho con las vacunas
pero entonces esta enfermedad nos ha
enseñado que a veces tenemos que dejar
de hacer pronósticos y tratar de
mantener lo que sabemos y adaptarnos a
los acontecimientos
las autoridades no descartan la
posibilidad de un tercer confinamiento
de poco fin hemos puesto a nuestro país
en dos cierres y en ambas ocasiones
porque lo hicimos porque los hospitales
estaban saturados todas las proyecciones
mostraban que estábamos teniendo cifras
de infección que podrían estar llegando
a 50 mil casos diarios ahora es otro
cierre una medida que tomaremos en
cualquier caso no puedo decírselo con
seguridad en cualquier caso lo que puedo
decirles es que la propagación del virus
sigue siendo preocupante dentro del país
en medio de los temores que desata la
variante británica del virus francia ha
visto como la cantidad de personas en
uso ha superado las 2800 por primera vez
en un mes las vacunas apenas han llegado
a cerca de 500 mil personas